[Music]
my husband was killed in a far away
land this place is so bar and I can't
understand what you would have seen out
here there she is far away
down welcome to Australia this should be
interesting it's all very Outback
Adventure isn't it I'm not saying this
for
[Music]
everyone
who are you I Nilla he's all Aline I'm
not good with
children when you first come to this
land you look but do not see now you get
her eyes open for the first
time I am going to bring Far Away Downs
back to
life Nala will you help me
yes Sergeant Callahan on the police
there's a half blood Aboriginal child
out here somewhere run I thought we
might put him in the good hands of the
church get off my
property to save this house I need money
out here your cattle's worth more than
your
land move on what are you doing
Cy a cattle station is like a country
and you have no one to protect
it
we can't let them win we won't feel it
in the now we going to do a drive with
just me and my two
men that's plenty old enough he is a
child if he doesn't get you'll have no
country no
Story the Japanese are coming we must
evacuate whatever happens whatever ever
it takes we'll be together I believe
you the only thing you really own is
your
story just trying to live a good
[Music]
one